entre les années 70 et aujourd’hui plus
de la moitié des boîtes de nuit ont
fermé en France et ce n'est pas que le
résultat de la pandémie et du covid en
fait ça illustre un profond changement
les jeunes ne font plus la fête ainsi
ils font la fête mais vraiment plus de
la même façon et c'est assez passionnant
à analyser on va donc se plonger dans
cette question aujourd'hui une question
qui finalement ne concerne tous mais
avant ça si comme moi vous aimez passer
de temps en temps aussi des soirées
chill chez vous à lire un livre ou autre
je suis très content de vous annoncer
que cette vidéo est réalisée en
collaboration avec nextory en fait c'est
la seule application de lecture qui
propose à la fois des livres numériques
des livres audio de la presse et même
des BD tout ça donc sur la même
plateforme et sur la même application
alors personnellement je trouve que
c'est très pratique je l'utilise par
exemple pour lire des livres à titre
personnel c'était le cas par exemple du
roman impact d'Olivier norek un roman
dont je vous avais déjà parlé il me
semble mais qui avait été vraiment l'un
de mes coups de cœur en 2022 et je m'en
c'est pas mal pour lire la presse par
exemple le magazine Society que je lis
régulièrement qui est disponible dessus
bref c'est vraiment top avec cette
diversité de contenu qui est disponible
et je suis sûr qu'elle pourrait aussi
vous plaire autant qu'à moi parce qu'il
y a vraiment tout dépollards des
romances ou même des livres de
développement personnel il y a vraiment
pour tous les goûts du coup si jamais ça
vous intéresse ça fonctionne par
abonnement le premier est à 9,99 € par
mois et ça vous donne accès à deux
livres audio par mois dans la limite de
15 heures d'écoute et à tout le reste
donc tous les livres que j'évoquais par
ailleurs ou encore les magazines en
illimité et la bonne nouvelle c'est que
avant de vous engager avec mon lien qui
est directement en description vous
pouvez avoir 45 jours gratuits pour
tester justement tous les contenus du
coup merci à eux et n'hésitez pas à le
découvrir alors plusieurs études vont
dans le même sens les jeunes ce sont
lassés des boîtes de nuit
et aujourd'hui on va pas parler que des
boîtes de nuit mais c'est un bon début
pour essayer d'analyser tout ça ce
mouvement semble assez répandu partout
en Europe on peut noter par exemple la
baisse du nombre de visiteurs annuels en
boîte de nuit au Royaume-Uni avant même
le covid ça avait chuté de 23% en 5 ans
la première chose qu'on peut noter qui
peut permettre d'expliquer cette baisse
de fréquentation des boîtes de nuit et
bien les plus jeunes préfèrent souvent
faire moins d'événements mais des
événements plus gros doux par exemple le
succès des festivals en France par
exemple qui rencontre toujours un succès
d'affluence et du coup quand on sort de
ces gros événements comme des festivals
on a tendance à prendre une journée
entière et une soirée entière voir un
week-end entier et bien on a tendance à
privilégier les restaurants ou alors les
bars plutôt que les boîtes alors
première chose qui peut expliquer cette
baisse de la fréquentation des boîtes de
nuit il y a une difficulté à convaincre
ses amis de sortir la flemme finalement
ou l'envie en tout cas de rester à la
maison et le journaliste Vincent
kochbert qualifie même notre génération
de génération indoor vont une génération
qui préférerait en général l'intérieur à
l'extérieur et qui favoriserait
finalement le cocon de son appartement
ou de sa maison pour les plus chanceux
plutôt que les sorties alors évidemment
là dessus à la pandémie semble avoir
joué un rôle avec la découverte de
nouvelles formes d'activités ça peut
être des séries ça peut être du jeu
vidéo découvert à titre personnel que je
prenais du plaisir visiblement à
enchaîner les défaites sur valorante
mais ça peut être aussi évidemment du
coup la lecture avec par exemple nextory
dont on parlait à l'instant deuxième
explication très rapidement peut-être la
plus importante elle est d'ordre
financière on en parle beaucoup sur
cette chaîne mais évidemment la
précarité des jeunes c'est l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles et bien le fait
d'aller faire la queue dans le froid
pour payer une entrée en boîte 20 euros
ne nous tente pas forcément autant
là-dessus le cabinet de conseils de loi
a mené une étude qui montre que la plus
grande préoccupation des jeunes
aujourd'hui c'était le coût de la vie
près de la moitié des 15000 jeunes
interrogés disaient en fait vivre en
ayant du mal à joindre les deux bouts du
coup forcément les sorties en boîte de
nuit apparaissent comme une dépense
parfois superflue et des alternatives
peuvent émerger par exemple la question
des festivals on est une l'idée avec un
festival c'est en payant une place pour
un weekend pour une journée de
multiplier les concerts multiplier
finalement les activités d'un seul coup
et par ailleurs d'autres alternatives
comme par exemple les bars de nuit
restent populaires un bar de nuit vous
avez pas forcément un prix à payer à
l'entrée vous êtes beaucoup plus libre
finalement là-dessus et donc forcément
ça peut attirer d'un point de vue
financier et pour expliquer ce déclin
relatif de la fête ou en tout cas des
boîtes de nuit il ressort aussi une
autre raison qui est cité par de
nombreux jeunes c'est le fait qu'ils
soient beaucoup moins intéressés par
l'alcool ou plus généralement en fait
les drogues quoi qu'est-ce que tu viens
de dire et attention évidemment
là-dessus il y a pas besoin de prendre
de l'alcool ou des drogues pour faire la
fête ou danser quoi mais simplement dans
l'imaginaire collectif et bien se rendre
en boîte de nuit c'est souvent associé
avec le fait de consommer de l'alcool et
donc c'est intéressant quand même de se
pencher sur le sujet pour pas trop trop
la gueule non plus
j'aime la vie vous n'avez peut-être pas
forcément constaté autour de vous en
tout cas dans les chiffres on note une
vraie tendance à consommer moins
d'alcool dans tout le monde en
particulier dans les pays occidentaux à
fort niveau de revenus et donc la France
fait partie de cette catégorie là à
l'échelle internationale ça se voit en
particulier chez ce que l'on appelle du
coup la génération Z la génération Z
c'est une autre génération moi je suis
né en 97 et c'est la génération née
entre 97 et 2010 une étude de grande
ampleur au Royaume-Uni a notamment
montré que les 16-25 ans constituaient
le groupe d'âge le plus propice à être
totalement abstinent donc ne pas prendre
du tout d'alcool ou de drogue avec 26%
d'entre eux par exemple qui ne buvaient
pas et c'est donc un chiffre qui est
beaucoup plus important que chez les
boomers entre guillemets donc ceux qui
ont plus de 55 ans qui sont seulement
15% à ne pas boire et là-dessus
d'ailleurs les chiffres en France ces
derniers jours vont absolument dans le
même sens bon après attention ça veut
pas dire que plus personne ne boit chez
les jeunes en fait il y a une forme
d'ailleurs de polarisation qui est
observée par exemple en Suède on a en
fait une partie croissante des jeunes
qui boit de moins en moins bien en
parallèle une autre partie de ces jeunes
qui de son côté au contraire boit de
plus en plus intensément ce qu'on
observe donc c'est que l'alcool a
longtemps été perçu comme une forme de
rite de passage vers l'âge adulte avec
le fait de boire parfois en grande
quantité lors de soirée ou autre on peut
penser évidemment aux soirées étudiantes
aux soirées de week-end d'intégration
qui reste des moments où l'alcool est
très très présent avec tous les débats
qu'il y a autour
[Musique]
Lola mais ce qu'on observe donc tout de
même c'est que ce rythme de passage à
l'âge adulte via l'alcool et tout de
même quelque chose qui est de moins en
moins présent au fil des années et ce un
petit peu partout dans le monde alors
pourquoi est-ce que les jeunes boivent
de moins en moins d'alcool là-dessus on
pourrait en parler pendant longtemps on
en a déjà parlé d'ailleurs dans le
format des actualités du jour que ce
soit sur Youtube ou alors en podcast
mais déjà l'un des éléments qu'on peut
noter c'est que souvent faut pas faire
de généralités mais souvent les jeunes
aiment de moins en moins prendre des
risques que par le passé là-dessus et je
vous mets des liens d'études en
description plusieurs recherches
anglo-saxonnes l'ont prouvé notre
volonté de nous mettre en danger diminue
de génération en génération ça concerne
donc forcément la consommation d'alcool
qui peut comporter des risques et en
fait plus largement consommation de
drogue ou encore les relations sexuelles
sans protection et l'une des principales
explications c'est que nous sommes
aujourd'hui davantage au courant des
risques qui peuvent être associés à tout
un tas de pratiques
notamment donc une consommation d'alcool
qui serait moins maîtrisée parce que
trop régulière ou alors trop intense par
moment on connaît mieux donc les impacts
sur notre santé qu'auparavant et c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs lié à des campagnes
de prévention qui ont été menées
notamment par l'État CRS années la bonne
santé n'a rien à voir avec l'alcool ce
mouvement de société on peut le
constater aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
par exemple avec le hashtag sur TikTok
sobertock qui valorise donc l'arrêt de
l'alcool ce hashtag compte d'ailleurs
près d'un milliard de vues cumulées bref
gardez le contrôle faire des choix
raisonnables c'est devenu quelque chose
de beaucoup plus valorisé socialement
évidemment donc l'alcool n'a pas
totalement disparu y compris chez les
jeunes mais simplement ce n'est pas
autant valorisé de boire en tout cas
intensément ou alors très régulièrement
mais tout cela est aussi lié à notre
réputation en ligne c'est quelque chose
que montre par exemple une étude de
Google qui est destinée à mieux
comprendre le comportement des jeunes
face à l'alcool près de la moitié des
jeunes de la génération Z dont je vous
parlais à l'instant disent que leur
image sur les réseaux sociaux leur
importe lorsqu'ils sortent pour boire et
sociabiliser et à l'heure où tout est
public évidemment sur les réseaux d'une
certaine manière on veut éviter qu'une
vidéo embarrassante de nous bourrés soit
publiés et vu par n'importe qui ce qui
bien sûr ne veut pas dire qu'on arrête
totalement de sortir mais plutôt donc
qu'on sort différemment moi
régulièrement et pour des événements
potentiellement plus exceptionnels par
exemple les festivals bon ça c'est pour
des arguments ou des explications de
court terme mais c'est vraiment
passionnant de voir que c'est une
tendance en fait de plus long terme
c'est la thèse que défend par exemple
Jérémy Pelletier qui est sociologue et
directeur des études à la Fondation Jean
Jaurès la publier un livre qui s'appelle
la fête est finie alors bien sûr la
pandémie a mis un coup d'arrêt à la fête
puisque la fête d'un coup était
considérée comme une activité non
essentielle la fermeture à compter de ce
soir minuit de tous les lieux recevants
du public non indispensable à la vie du
pays sauf peut-être dans certains pays
par exemple avec un certain Premier
ministre britannique qui continu
certaines soirées
il n'a pas fallu attendre le covid pour
que les balles populaires soient
finalement on voit d'extinction en effet
les boîtes de nuit par exemple ont
commencé à fermer avant même la pandémie
de covid du coup on pourrait se poser
cette question est-ce que la fête
finalement est essentielle bien je sais
pas vous à titre personnel j'aurais
tendance à dire que oui évidemment c'est
quelque chose d'essentiel mais ce qui
explique Jérémy Pelletier c'est que les
réseaux sociaux ont pas mal remplacé en
fait certaines fonctionnalités de la
fête si on peut dire ça de façon un peu
schématique et l'un des exemples qui est
donné par Jérémy Pelletier dans son
ouvrage c'est la question des lieux de
rencontre ou de séduction en effet les
bottes de nuit pourront longtemps et
c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui c'est
aussi vu comme un lieu de rencontre or
et bien Jérémy Pelletier explique dans
son ouvrage que bien les applications de
rencontre finalement répondent à une
flemme de la cour amoureuse je cite
pourquoi se rendre à une fête au risque
de ne rien trouver de me faire recaler
et de perdre mon temps à discuter alors
que je peux choisir mon avec ou ma meuf
sur un catalogue sans que personne ne
voit si jamais cela se passe bien ou mal
ce qui explique donc Jérémy Pelletier
c'est que en boîte de nuit ou en général
dans des lieux de fait comme cela la
réussite ou l'échec d'une rencontre est
visible par tous à ce moment-là donc la
fête ne joue plus le rôle essentiel de
socialisation qu'elle jouait auparavant
ou en tout cas vous l'aurez compris elle
se voit concurrencer par les réseaux
sociaux et là en l'occurrence on parlait
de la question de la rencontre mais les
réseaux sociaux peuvent remplacer je dis
ça avec des grosses guillemets certains
aspects de la fête ou certains aspects
des boîtes de nuit la question de son
statut social plus généralement au sein
de la société peut passer par d'autres
choses là aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
l'historien des religions myrtille en
1956 raconte à quel point la fête
faisait partie pendant longtemps d'une
forme de temporalité à part on avait en
fait pendant longtemps le temps profane
donc par définition le calendrier
habituel qui voit ce succéder des jours
qui finalement se ressemblent tous et de
temps en temps par l'intermédiaire des
fêtes bien ont créé une rupture dans
cette vision un petit peu linéaire on
décide donc de sortir de notre routine
pour vivre autre chose un peu comme si
on voulait faire un trou dans le emploi
du temps pour lâcher prise et passer à
autre chose dans l'histoire de la Grèce
antique par exemple vers 1500 avant
Jésus-Christ les fêtes étaient
systématiquement liées un temps sacré
que Eliade définit comme un moment où
les Grecs essayaient de communier avec
les dieux on peut prendre l'exemple des
dionysis c'était des festivités qui
avaient lieu tous les ans à la même
époque en Grèce antique en l'honneur du
dieu Dionysos divinité du vin et de
l'ivresse pendant c'est fait le temps
sacré faisait irruption dans le temps
profane toutes les activités de la Ville
s'arrêtaient le calendrier était mis
comme en pause et chaque citoyen devait
participer même les prisonniers étaient
libérés à l'occasion de cette fête bref
vous l'aurez compris à l'époque et
pendant longtemps c'est fait et était
exceptionnel elles étaient espacées dans
le temps et dans le calendrier justement
pour casser la routine et ne pas devenir
habituel or aujourd'hui pour le penseur
Philippe Murray trop de fêtes tu l'as
faites il a inventé de son côté le
personnage d'homo festivus représentatif
selon lui de l'époque contemporaine en
gros à trop vouloir mettre de la fête
partout et faire de tout une fête que ce
soit par exemple la fête des voisins des
fêtes au travail avec ses collègues des
fêtes de divorce même alors à ce
moment-là la fête est finalement nulle
part ce côté exceptionnel de la fête
dont je vous parlais juste avant il
existe alors plus vraiment on a plus
totalement cet aspect de séparation
entre le temps de la fête et le reste du
calendrier les entre le moment du
divertissement et les moments de sérieux
sont plus flous que jamais tout cela
fait donc que le moment de fête n'est
finalement plus exceptionnel même si
c'est encore le cas pour certains
moments évidemment les anniversaires ont
encore le Nouvel An dernier élément
essentiel pour comprendre cette question
la question du lâcher prise est-ce que
la fête finalement ne demande pas un
certain degré de lâcher prise en effet
la fête faut pas l'oublier c'est aussi
et surtout en théorie un moment de
légèreté absolue le philosophe
contemporain Michael faussel qui est
professeur de philosophie à politique et
spécialiste de la pensée d'Emmanuel Kant
j'espère que ça vous rappelle pas de
mauvais souvenirs c'est intéressé à ce
sujet et en fait dans un petit essai
passionnant qui s'appelle tout
simplement la nuit il cite donc ces
expériences dans ces nuits berlinoises
en Allemagne en particulier dans le
fameux club le bergane célèbre pour ses
grandes soirées techno et ses videurs
pas toujours commode pour lui ces
expériences sont bel et bien des moments
de lâcher prise mais pourtant ce n'est
pas facile de totalement lâcher prise
et deux raisons importantes ressortent
la première raison c'est la crainte de
son image en cas de vidéo par exemple
prise et diffusée sur les réseaux
sociaux ou autre mais surtout la
deuxième raison qui est avancée c'est la
crainte pour sa sécurité le mouvement me
too par exemple a mis en lumière des
agressions et des agissements qui
rendent forcément difficile tout lâcher
prise mais Michael faussel n'a pas perdu
tout espoir il espère qu'on pourra
retrouver ses expériences collectives
des moments profondément certes un
productifs mais égalitaire est très
positif parce que forcément ces instants
sont hors du temps et ils sont cruciaux
ils nous permettent de nous réunir sans
aucune raison précise à part celle de
profiter de l'instant présent et
simplement d'être ensemble
en tout cas malgré les fermetures
importantes pour les boîtes de nuit qui
restent et bien ils ont retrouvé près de
80% de leur fréquentation d'avant
pandémie on verra donc comment ça évolue
en tout cas courage à tous ceux qui
évoluent dans ce milieu dans le monde de
la nuit alors est-ce qu'on peut sauver
la fête et si oui comment dites moi
directement dans les commentaires ce que
vous en pensez on est vous l'avez vu
aujourd'hui sur une vidéo et un sujet
qui est peut-être plus philosophique que
d'habitude c'est quelque chose qu'on
voulait tester aujourd'hui n'hésitez pas
à me dire ce que vous en pensez
directement dans les commentaires et si
jamais ça vous a plu vous pouvez vous
abonner pour nous soutenir on est
quasiment un million d'abonnés sur cette
deuxième chaîne je le rappelle c'est une
chaîne qui vient en complément de la
chaîne des actus du jour merci beaucoup
pour votre confiance merci aussi à
dextorique et donc partenaire de cette
vidéo je vous mets les liens en
description merci aussi à Charlotte qui
est passionné et diplômé de philosophie
et qui a travaillé avec moi sur cette
vidéo elle a un compte qui s'appelle
élévation fr sur Instagram et sur Tik
Tok qui parle de philosophie d'une
manière ancrée à l'actualité et au sujet
de société on n'est pas du tout sur de
la philo très classique disons comme
vous pouvez le voir notamment en cours
c'est sur quelque chose qui est très lié
au sujet qui nous préoccupe au quotidien
un peu comme cette vidéo du coup je vous
invite à suivre son compte il y a aussi
une newsletter Lofi que je suis à titre
personnel très régulièrement je vous
mets là aussi des liens en description
ça peut vous aider notamment chez vous
passer le bac de philo cette année ou
même en général vous allez le voir c'est
vraiment passionnant voilà écoutez je
crois que j'ai tout dit prenez soin de
vous présenter nos proches et puis je
vous dis à très vite sur cette chaîne ou
alors sur la chaîne des actus du jour